so we're making a cashew cheese sauce
this time we're going to pour it over
this beautiful violet cauliflower this
is also the sauce it's in our cookbook
that we pour over our nachos so it's
super tasty it's made with cashews
it also has nutritional yeast in it
which is a fantastic source of b12 yes
so nutritional least good for a key
ingredient in cashew cheese sauce a lot
of people use the b12 argument as a
reason to not adopt a plant-based diet
but there are a couple of few simple
fixes to this things like this which
have b12 minute this actually has one
serving of this has 150% of 12 so what
you want to do is you're going to pulse
this is a cup and a half of the raw
organic cashews and you're gonna you're
going to pulse it until it comes like
mealy but you don't want it to stick
together
I think that's about right come here let
me show you what that looks like it's
not sticking together and it's sort of
mealy in consistency okay so what we're
gonna do right away add the nutritional
yeast so much of that half a cup so
we're just gonna sprinkle that in we're
gonna add a little sea salt and again
this is in our cross records about the
teaspoon of garlic cut up an eighth of a
teaspoon of pepper just a little bit not
much
okay
okay so what we're going to pulse it
again so it blasts
okay and then we have over here in the
saucepan we have a half a cup of canola
oil and two and a half cups of
unsweetened organic soil so I have a
couple things to say about that of
course we know that canola oil is not
the best thing for you
and so we've experimented with a couple
other different kind of oils that are
healthier the problem is it just doesn't
taste good so we tried flaxseed oil
coconut oil olive oil olive oil the one
that we still need to test is grapeseed
oil
so stay tuned because we may have a new
version of this for now we're using
canola oil that's the oil that makes it
taste the best we need to have a very
sort of neutral taste but but we're not
unaware that it's not the healthiest
choice to use ok so what we're going to
do is we're going to turn this off
okay now though while it's continuing to
go through you're going to take a
quarter cup of miso paste okay organic
miso paste you can find it in the
refrigerated section Whole Foods or any
old home
Stewart
okay now start to set up a little bit
and it's more of a sauce type
consistency
so how long after we make this should
you need it
almost immediately well the truth is you
can store it in the refrigerator for a
few days so it just gets hard you have
to heat it up again but it's um it's hot
you know so you're supposed to eat it
immediately yeah the thing is you should
eat it right away it starts to kind of
congeal a little bit over time so it's
kind of like cheese like a cheese like a
nacho cheese again stuffs great on chips
for nachos we do